[Music]
thank you
one particularly complex and important
character in Philip K Dick's the man in
the High Castle is this guy Robert
children who is an American Antiquities
dealer as a matter of fact he is as
we're going to find out at least in his
own eyes the best in the game and he's
really a
quite interesting character through what
he reveals about himself and about the
mindset that he represents he is a
business person he's also got all sorts
of personal interests and Reflections
he's driven in part by insecurity and we
might even say on some level resentment
and also by desire desire not just for
making a lot of money or security but
for figuring out where he fits within
this world that he lives in in the
Pacific States of America where the
Japanese essentially dominate they are
at the top of the hierarchy and he's
part of what we could call the Demi
moaned that caters to them he's American
but he gets treated better than many
Americans because of his particular
business
arrangements with them
and I think from the very beginning we
see this interesting
conflict and contrast between different
ways in which he is you could say
involved with these these Japanese and I
think that tagumi and
um the couple the casuras are a great
case in point we begin at the very start
of the novel with children who is
waiting for this particular item to come
and to go me calls and tagomi is not
happy with the fact that children hasn't
delivered on this this particular
artifact right a civil war recruiting
poster and children says well you know
we'll have to do some sort of
substitution you know and uh
tagomi actually mispronounces his name
insult within the code that made
children's ears burn Place pulled the
Dreadful mortification of their
situation and we read Robert childen's
aspirations and fears and torments Rose
up and exposed themselves swamped him
stomping his tongue he stammered his
hand sticky on the phone
and he says well I can come up with some
other substitutes and they make an
appointment then this couple comes in
young Japanese couple and we've already
talked about them at length so I don't
need to read the the passages but what
we see is they have a very different
attitude towards children they don't
represent the old right and they end up
having a great conversation together
and he says oh I can fall in love with
this woman and in fact he actually is
Desiring Betty kasura so let's just read
this afterward as the couple strolled
from his store children stood hands
behind his back watching the street Joy
so a different kind of affect right
if all business days were like this but
it was more than business the success of
his story it was a chance to meet a
young Japanese couple socially
on a basis of acceptance of him as a man
rather than as him as a yank or at best
a Tradesman Who Sold art objects these
new people of the rising generation who
did not remember the days before the war
even the war themselves they were the
hope of the world Place difference did
not have the significance for them it
will end Sheldon thought someday the
very idea of place not governed in
governing but people and so this sounds
you know very nice right
but we see that this sort of egalitarian
Vision gives way to fears
he trembled with fear imagining himself
knocking on their door being admitted no
doubt offered to you would he do the
right thing know the proper act and
utterance at every moment or would he
disgrace himself like an animal by some
dismal faux pas and then he's sort of
like thinking about the possibility of a
Japanese woman and a yank himself man
right is is there a possibility for this
and
um you know he realizes that that's
that's not going to be the the case
unless maybe he does something and we're
going to see that happen a little bit
later on
now we've already seen a little bit of
the complexity of his attitudes and
affects as he's going to take the
possible substitutes to the Nippon Times
building for his appointment with Mr
tagomi of the trade Mission we see a lot
of interesting meditations that he's
engaging in or Reflections guiltily he
woke himself too much to plan no time
for a midday does was he absolutely
properly dressed to enter the Nippon
Times building possibly he would faint
in the high-speed elevator but he had
motion illness tablets with him the
various modes of address he knew them
who to treat politely who to treat
rudely
he knew them
be Brusque with the doorman elevator
operator receptionist guide any
janitorial person bow to any Japanese of
course even if it obliged him to Bow
hundreds of times but the pinox nebulous
area right these are white people who
are serving the Japanese as well bow but
look straight through them as if they
did not exist did that cover every
situation then well what about a
visiting Foreigner Germans could often
be seen at the trade missions as well as
neutrals and then he might also see a
slave German or South ships docked at
the Port of San Francisco all the time
and blacks occasionally were allowed off
for short intervals how would he deal
with this and he actually thinks to
himself
you know I'd enjoy carrying my own stuff
but
you know I'd be able to reveal how I
actually think about things but I can't
do that because people might look down
on me and those black slaves lurking
about they would scorn and humiliate me
as well to have those beneath me to feel
their contempt and he's thinking about
the Chinese person who's peddling his
pedicab right and he says Ah the Germans
are responsible for this situation but
we see this really interesting
ambivalence here right
he admires the Germans uh children
doesn't
disregard or
find repugnant the racial hierarchy that
has been established he's just not happy
about his own placement in it as a white
American right so there's this complex
attitude about well who do I bow to who
do I show contempt to and he's not even
sure why he looks at things the way he
does right he just sort of
um you know thinks of of these as well
this is the way the world is today I
wish it could be different but it's not
and then we get these interesting
Reflections on his own Beginnings right
so we have a elderly Japanese ex-army
man a major Ito humo who comes in and
gives children his first inkling about
what might be done with his line of
merchandise and he explains that he's
interested in collecting these cards and
children is able to explain to him what
the cards were actually used for and
then he talks about bottle caps and
children begins his business so by
stages he'd gotten into it others had
opened similar places taking advantage
of the ever-growing Japanese craze for
Americana but children had always kept
his Edge right and then he has this sort
of Flash oh you know usually the clients
are like this major oh but what if it's
not a Japanese client that I'm getting
these things ready for to be gifted to
through tagomian this could be a
catastrophe right
so a lot of interesting stuff happening
in chapter two revealing children and we
learn way way more about him in his
encounter with the casuras at their
house an incredible ambiguity or
ambivalence
within children himself on the one hand
he's like oh these Japanese the sense of
Wabi to be so close to the way the Dao
wouldn't it be amazing he's recognizing
something there
and he loves engaging with them but he
can't help putting his foot in his mouth
arguing politics in a way that shows
that he's not really egalitarian oh you
know the Russian hordes would have
overcome us if you Japanese and the
Nazis hadn't beaten the Allies in World
War II and the casuras they're not cool
with that sort of thing although they
treat him quite well and he he thinks to
himself you know
how much I have to learn they're so
grateful and polite and I the white
Barbarian it is true
right he thinks to himself my wits were
scrambled by the drink fatigue and
nervousness can I do it I will never be
invited back anyhow it's already too
late he felt despair
then they begin discussing the
grasshopper lay heavy and we see this
other side
not revealed in discourse but in his
thoughts of children where he thinks to
himself
you know these people are completely
different
I'm trying to pretend these Japanese and
I are alike but observe even when I
burst out as to my gratification they
won the war there's still no Common
Ground what words mean to me is sharp
contrast vis-a-vis them their brains are
different Souls likewise witness them
drinking from English bone china cups
eating with U.S silver listening to
negro style of music it's all on the
surface
advantage of wealth and power makes us
available to them but it's air zots as
the day is long and then he says to
himself only the white races are endowed
with creativity and yet I must bump head
to floor with these two think about how
it would have been if we had won we
would have crushed them out of existence
there's a kind of nastiness here on his
part isn't there
and so
you know he treats them on the one hand
as if they're much better on the other
hand they're mere imitators right and
this brings us speaking of imitation to
the historicity problem that we see
happening over several chapters and
again paradoxes involved in this
children character and his stances on
things so we begin with Frank Frank
coming into the store and initiating
this entire sequence of events having to
do with historicity he's pretending to
be an admiral's gentleman Admiral harusa
whose ship is in and he says you know
I'm I'm going to pay you a deposit of
fifteen thousand dollars and children is
like well
take a look at this pistol and then we
get Frank saying
this is a fake
can it be that you can't even tell the
difference between fakes
imitations and real works he says you've
been deceived and he says well I can't
buy these and now children goes into
despair he's worried about being
revealed and then he says to himself
I am ruined I've lost a fifteen thousand
dollar sale and my reputation if this
gets out if that man Admiral harish's
gentleman is not discreet I'll kill
myself he decided I've lost place I
cannot go on that's a fact on the other
hand though maybe the man lied or he
aired so he sends it out and has it
analyzed and it turns out it is a fake
and so children starts raising some hell
right he uh tells Ray Calvin you know
you are selling me fakes I want my money
back Ray uh then talks to uh Windham
Matson and says your fakes are no good
and this Cascades a whole bunch of
problems
now interestingly this is going to lead
to Frank Frank originally Frank fink a
Jew from New York City being identified
by the kempathy and we learn that
Sheldon
um
will have all sorts of views on Law and
Order and the Jews and all of that sort
of stuff so uh he has to sign a paper
and uh then Sheldon is thinking to
himself you know I guess they got him
whatever he was up to Great relief they
work fast all right we live in a society
of Law and Order where Jews can't pull
their subtleties on the innocent we're
protected I don't know why I didn't
recognize the racial characteristics
when I saw him evidently I'm easily
deceived and he thinks without law I'd
be at their Mercy he could have
convinced me of anything it's a form of
hypnosis they control they can control
an entire Society now he's buying into
all sorts of crazy propaganda about
Jewish people that the Nazis have put
out and as we also know one of the Nazi
propaganda ideas is that Jews themselves
are sort of like the Japanese in
Sheldon's view only imitative they can't
have any genuine creativity of their own
however as it's going to turn out
they do because
uh
the Ed Frank jewelry that's going to get
displayed has this characteristic of
whoo
this incredibly
important transcendent
quality that the Artisan has put into it
so now we move ahead to
um chapter nine where
of course Frank can't go in because he's
already engaged under disguise with
Robert Sheldon and so his uh friend and
partner goes in and begins you know
starting to try to sell this stuff and
children is essentially going to take
advantage of him he'll say listen you
can put all your stuff out I'll take a
look at it but you know this is new
stuff this is untested I don't know if
there's a market for this at all I'll
I'll let you sell it here on consignment
I'll let you keep you know two-thirds of
it and I'll take one-third
otherwise you know
there's no sales I don't have to take
any risks and so you know Ed says that's
that's all right he has to agree to it
and then Sheldon thinks to himself you
know this is a great opportunity I'm
going to Mark these up we'll make more
money and
I can send one of these to Betty kasuro
this can be a way for me to open the
door to a relationship with her I'll
have to go through her husband so that
he doesn't actually suspect now this is
going to lead us to something that
reveals a different possibility for
Robert childon and this is happening in
chapter 11. we find that the jewelry
never made its way
to Betty as a matter of fact Paul kept
it and at first was kind of laughing
about it then showed it to his friends
but
Paul realized
it has this
incredible quality something new on the
face of the Earth and then Paul poses
Robert children with a conundrum on the
one hand
Paul has an acquaintance a business
owner who is interested in taking these
bits of jewelry made by American
Artisans and turning them into good luck
charms that can be sold mass-produced
down in South America it will make
Robert and the artist very very wealthy
and Robert has to take charge of this
so Robert at first goes along with it
and he says
um you know
all all
um
go ahead and do this and but he realizes
his children he's actually saying which
are you Robert he who the Oracle calls
the inferior man the one who's going to
seek wealth or that other for whom all
the good advice is meant in the E Jing
the Oracle you have to decide here you
may Trot on one way or the other but not
both here's the moment of choice where
do you commit yourself
and at first we see children saying I
will follow your advice
um I will leave to visit the Importer
Paul doesn't seem pleased by this
and he says do the American Artisans who
made this piece by hand the labor of
their own personal bodies will they play
along and children says well I at Hazard
they they could be persuaded and Paul
says yes I suppose so and then Sheldon
realizes oh man
I've been taken
the whole Affair is a cruel dismissal of
American efforts taking place before his
eyes that's how the Japanese ruled not
crudely but with subtlety Ingenuity
Timeless cunning we are barbarians
compared to them right and children says
he's broken me humiliated me and my race
so now you know although in the past he
was willing to say oh the Japanese not
really creative or anything like that
he's he's facing up to the fact that
they actually are and Paul has given him
a kind of test
and then the test changes
right
he says to the to Paul I am humiliated
and he says I I am proud of this work
there can be no consideration of trashy
good luck charms I reject so that now
he's showing he is the superior person
but he goes further
and he says
the men who made this are American Proud
artists myself included he's identifying
with Americans in a very different way
not just as Warriors but as artists and
notice that it's the Jew Frank Frank who
has created this piece and children is
wrong about Frank entirely right
he says
to suggest trashy good luck charms
therefore insults us and I ask for an
apology
Paul then
actually says forgive my arrogant
imposition Robert children says all
right and they shake hands and Sheldon
says I have lived through and out he
knew all over grace of God had existed
at the exact moment for me another time
otherwise could I ever dare once more
press my luck probably not
now this is not the very end of children
in the story to go me after his fight
with the SD men in which he kills two of
them in the very same Nippon Times
building
comes to try to sell back the pistol and
children who was previously intimidated
by tagomi is now acting as an equal to
him and says no no I'm not going to take
it into gomi accept that and then
children says I've got something else to
show you are you free for the moment and
he says I show these ruthlessly to each
of my customers now that's very
interesting children has found something
that actually
motivates him besides social climbing
besides his resentments besides
sexuality besides making money and his
fears right he tells to go me
that this can generate a new view in
your heart and he says I sense in these
the contracted germ of the future
tagomi comes back into the store after
initially refusing and Sheldon sells it
to him and children says you know if it
doesn't work out for you I'll take it
back on full credit
and here's the last part with him this
will calm you Mr Children said he laid
out a single small silver triangle
ornamented with Hollow drops black
beneath bright and light filled above
thank you tagomi said so we see not a
complete resolution with Robert Sheldon
but a sort of Advance into the future
he hasn't become a thoroughly good
person
but it has become better
how much has he left behind his previous
attitudes we don't really know because
that's where the matter ends but there
is hope for this rather squirrely venial
comparing himself to everybody else sort
of character that is Robert childen